a construção de um país pós racial de um
brasil que não nós não nos teríamos de
preocupar com a cor da pele das pessoas
uma raça das pessoas e com o problema do
racismo é uma meta que eu compartilho
mas infelizmente é ainda uma ficção
eu desde 1984
me dedico a fazer filmes a escrever
textos livros todos eles buscando como
nesse filme que eu vou gastar um pequeno
trecho algumas imagens filhas do vento
dedicando a falar dos nossos sonhos das
nossas angústias das nossas fantasias
dos nossos desejos
enquanto a população afro descendente
a minha o meu esforço é demonstrar que a
vivência que o fato de ser ter origem
negra no brasil isso significa e que nós
temos uma especialidade de em olhar
nossa realidade
entretanto já todo há 30 anos nessa área
eu sei eu continuo me perguntando até
quando o brasil vai negar a valorizar
aquilo que eu considero um dos maiores
patrimônios que nós temos que é a nossa
multirracial idade que o fato de sermos
um país construído por negros ou brancos
europeus ou asiáticos por orientais
afegãs ou seja grande leva de pessoas
vieram pra cá muitos deles se misturaram
mas infelizmente
as condições o fato de nós termos um
país misturado nos tornou o que nós
gostaríamos de ser um exemplo de
democracia racial
se pegarmos todos os dados estatísticos
referentes à realidade brasileira a
referente a ascensão profissional
mercado de trabalho violência policial
acesso à educação
nós em todos eles nós perceberemos que
sobre os negros recai os piores
indicadores ou seja infelizmente nós não
superamos o terrível passado
escravocrata
eu vou trazer dois exemplos aqui que não
são os exemplos mais recorrentes quando
se fala da persistência do assis no
brasil mas eu acho que são reveladores
ajudam a revelar essa essa terrível
realidade brasileira
a primeira primeiro exemplo sobre a
adoção de crianças negras
de acordo com o cadastro nacional de
adoção que foi divulgado em setembro
a primeira constatação é que a morte do
meu pai das crianças que estão esperando
serem adotadas são crianças negras
a segunda constatação é que somente 585
pessoas declararam entre aqueles que
fizeram o cadastro
buscando essa doação declararam que
gosta que aceitariam crianças negras
apenas 1537 delas declararam que
aceitariam crianças mexicanas morenas
paradas mas 10.173 delas declararam
abertamente que só aceitariam crianças
brancas ou seja cerca de 40% delas não
querem crianças negras e mestiças pegar
um outro exemplo que eu considero mais
trágico ainda e talvez um dos maiores
problemas do racismo no brasil na
atualidade que a violência policial
contra jovens negros aqui eu tô
trabalhando com dados do relatório do
observatório de favelas de 2014
eles fizeram a pesquisa do período de
2002 a 2010 e constataram que nesse
período o a criminalidade
a taxa de homicídios no brasil caiu de
20 para 15
esse é um bom a boa notícia entretanto
no mesmo período para os negros essa
taxa subiu de 34 para 36 dos
assassinatos em cada 100 mil habitantes
agora o pior de todos esses dados é que
o número de vítimas entre a população
negra e jovem dobrou em relação aos
brancos
ou seja utilizando também o caetano
veloso aqui a realidade continua brutal
para aqueles que são negros ou quase
negros e tão pobres as suas chances de
ascensão social estão infelizmente
condicionada a cor de suas velhas
eu tenho um amigo que tem uma frase que
eu gosto muito é manter o pólo professor
da uff chamado kabengele munanga ele diz
o seguinte o racismo no brasil um crime
perfeito que é um crime perfeito é
aquele que não deixa rastros
aquele que não levanta desconfiança
aquele em que quem comete o crime busca
aparentar ser um cidadão acima de
qualquer suspeita
mas no caso racial você tem um gráfico
grau máximo de perfeição do crime
perfeito que é quando o criminoso
consegue transferir para sua vítima
a responsabilidade pelo seu alto do seu
ato
vou dar alguns exemplos de crime
perfeito na sociedade brasileira
o primeiro deles
de vez em quando aparece na mídia que
acontece nos estádios de futebol
acho que vocês lembra o caso do goleiro
aranha
aranha foi chamado pela torcida
adversária de macaco de preto pedido
assim como vários outros jogadores
atirou uma banana contra ele
qual foi a atitude da sociedade diante
do caso
a atitude foi pedir que a aranha
consideração aquilo como natural como
fruto de uma paixão exacerbada do
torcedor o torcedor quando está
apaixonado pelo time e torcendo e não
sabe o que diz bem esse assunto virou um
assunto top da televisão ficou na mídia
por duas três semanas
curiosamente uma das pessoas
identificadas como agressora circulou
pelos programas de televisão
de agressor era quase que virou heroína
teve um grande jogador de futebol
brasileiro que disse que o que o aranha
não devia considerar aquilo que se ele
fizesse isso a história dele não chegar
onde chegou
ou seja onde está o crime perfeito aí o
crime perfeito é a pressão que se
vazasse quanto a vítima do racismo para
descaracterizar aquilo como racismo
o segundo filme é um outro exemplo do
crime perfeito vocês viram recentemente
com o ginasta ângelo assunção que foi
vítima de piadas racistas dos seus
colegas da confederação brasileira de
ginástica e receber o mesmo tipo de
pressão
eu pessoalmente quando era jovem e
entrei na universidade e comecei a
participar do movimento negro tinha um
black power sim de todo o tamanho
e é verdade é verdade
e comecei a freqüentar a casa de uma
amiga minha
uma jovem branca de classe média na casa
dela fazer trabalhos escolares palavras
e apesar do black power
a família dela me trataram superbem mas
aí um dia eu comecei a namorar com ela a
atitude da família dela foi que foi essa
veja aí naquela idade com 19 e com 22
anos de idade
eles falaram comigo você traiu a nossa
confiança
o que significa isso que eu quero é o
culpado
eu atravessei uma linha racial invisível
e provoque um disco de estúdio daquela
família
eu me transformei de vítima e agressor
atualmente eu creio que uma das formas
em que persiste racismo e ainda não foi
devidamente cuidado pela sociedade
brasileira é a forma que aparece na
infância das pessoas especialmente no
ensino fundamental que aquele momento
que a criança sai de casa sai do seio
familiar e vai conviver mais abertamente
com a sociedade
vou dar um exemplo recente disso a
garota lorena
um estudante de ensino fundamental em
são paulo na escola da cidade de são
paulo que foi vítima dos mesmos tipo de
xingamento que o irã recebeu pelos seus
colegas de classe
a primeira atitude dela foi correr para
a diretora e buscar um abraço eo apoio
da diretora e atitude da diretora foi
dizer não me meto nisso pior
a diretora disse pra ela peça desculpas
pior a diretora ao invés de punir os
agressores tirou ela da classe
transferiu ela de classe
é por isso que o racismo no brasil é um
crime perfeito
bem a minha área cinema rádio e tv com
vocês como já disse tudo nessa área há
cerca de 30 anos
o meu primeiro grande trabalho que me
tornou conhecido nacionalmente foi o
filme que eu também não sou gay
a pesquisa o livro que eu passei cinco
anos pesquisando sobre a história do
negro na telenovela brasileira
nós eu e mais 14 pessoas que trabalharam
comigo
examinamos mais de 590 se for ao ar
naquele período 62 a 98
nós constatamos coisas chocantes e foi
aí que eu percebi que a televisão ea
telenovela prática uma forma mais
sofisticada ainda de crime perfeito
é uma coisa chamada estética do
branqueamento
é sobre isso que eu quero falar mais
profundamente aqui hoje
em 90% aliasing um tenso das telenovelas
nós examinamos não aparecer nenhum negro
nem mesmo com figurante nem como
empregada doméstica ou nada e um terço
nos outros dois textos em cerca de 90
delas os negros apareciam como jagunços
serventes bandidos motoristas ou seja
apareceu uma representação da figura do
atraso ou como representação da
subalternidade na sociedade brasileira
como se os negros estivessem
predestinados e eternamente subalternas
a manter a escravidão
nós gostamos de dizer que nós somos um
país mestiço
portanto nós superamos o problema do
racismo porque nós só um mestiço
se assim fosse se nós tivéssemos
orgulhos e mexi su o natural é que
aqueles que são mestiços chamados
mulatos morenos seria o ideal de beleza
da televisão brasileira
vamos ver a carreira de dois grandes
nomes nelson xavier ea dira paes não
sabe é passou 20 anos da sua carreira
sem usar terno e gravata normalmente
fazendo o papel do pequeno comerciante
rancoroso do malandro do delegado que na
verdade quem mandava era a mulher dele
ou seja esse tipo de raça intermediária
que não é negro tem vergonha da sua
origem negra que quer ser branco e não
consegue por isso um ressentido a dira
paes
com essas fortes características
indígenas
essa 13 incrível passou mais de dez anos
só fazendo empregadinhas cômicas no city
cozzi da televisão ou seja do meu ponto
de vista cbx no brasil é uma condição de
passagem do inferior para o superior à
expectativa da sociedade brasileira é
que nós nos tornamos que nós tornamos as
novas gerações as nossas famílias e
pessoas brancas
se a base do crime perfeito da televisão
é porque ela reforça essa expectativa
social e aqueles que são escolhidos como
galãs como mocinhos da televisão
são aquelas pessoas que têm
características mais germânicas olhos
claros cabelos louros você estranhamente
a nossa publicidade à nossa televisão e
até mesmo nosso cinema blog basta é
insistir numa coisa que foi derrotada na
segunda guerra mundial que a afirmação
dos arianos como raça superior
essa coisa terrível
a nossa estética estética do
branqueamento é mais que o pagamento é
do arianismo e os negros só entram na
condição da representação do atraso da
figura o do exótico é o que também nós
podemos ver a publicidade brasileira
eu fiz uma pesquisa no google me
coloquei lá publicidade brasileira
apareceram páginas e mais páginas só com
brancos assim como você vê está
naturalizado para nós é como nós vemos
na televisão na televisão diariamente
acontece a mesma coisa quando aparece um
negro ele aparece assim na condição de
minoria um entre seis aqui é ter uma
representação positiva é quase exótico
nesse nesse tipo de representação
ou seja hoje nós estamos na segunda
metade do céu da segunda década do
século 21 o brasil a sexta economia do
mundo negocia com todos os continentes
a china se tornou o nosso maior parceiro
comercial a áfrica se fosse considerada
como um país seria o nosso quarto maior
parceiro comercial ou seja uma demanda
da sociedade brasileira é deformam a
nova geração de formar kaká quadros
capazes de compreender a diversidade do
mundo e respeitar a diversidade do mundo
que interage lá interagir com ela com
uma coisa natural e aprender isso dentro
de casa
portanto esses são os de vários desafios
que eu acho que não são os desafios do
futuro são os desafios do presente para
o presente a todos nós brancos negros
japoneses não importa a raça
eu creio que nós as questões que estão
colocadas para todos nós aqui e pra quem
me ouve
mv é como que nós só vamos fazer desse
país que é uma potência global e superar
destruir o seu complexo de vira latas
como é que nós vamos fazer nós vamos
perder a nossa mentalidade colonial a
persistência da mentalidade colonial que
considera os brancos arianos uma raça
superior como ideal de beleza de
características para o ser humano
diante desses desafios eu acho que
também nós temos de pensar como
assegurar que o país reconheça a enorme
contribuição da população negra na sua
história a contenção econômica
contribuição cultural artística no
esporte em vários campos
portanto diante de tudo isso né
eu acho que nós estamos diante de um
momento em que nós temos de pressionar o
governo pressionar as câmaras
legislativas
pressionar o sistema jurídico para que o
brasil adote uma nova concepção de mesa
de si mesmo a nova estética desse mês
baseada naquilo que nós somos um país
profundamente diversos racialmente eu
acho que nós temos que nos dedicar
também à convenceu seguido do segmento
empresarial que é quem financia as peças
publicitárias demandas peça publicitária
quem financia os programas de televisão
patrocínio da fia patrocina filmes a
abraçar essa idéia de que nós temos de
mudar a nossa estética com sua estética
baseada na multinacional idade na
diversidade humana
todos nós só temos a ganhar com isso
portanto eu creio que esse é o momento
de nós abandonamos o nosso complexo de
vira latas
esse é o momento de nós descolonizar mas
as nossas mentes
obrigado